es gibt wohl kaum einen bereich unseres
lebens in denen man nicht auf
verschwörungstheorien kreft die
mondlandung hat nie stattgefunden krebs
ist nicht heilbar oder flüchtlinge sind
alle verbrecher das ist natürlich
unsinn und wir fragten wieder weg und
doch wie schaut es mit den
verschwörungstheorien so wie nie und
sie sind gefährlich also wie erkennt
man verschwörungstheorien was haben die
illuminaten damit zu tun und warum gibt
es sie überhaupt jede sieben
wichtigsten fakten jetzt weg zum zweiten
fiction herzlich willkommen fakt ein
verschwörungs theorien gibt es schon
ewig damit eine richtig gute
verschwörungstheorie überhaupt
entstehen kann muss ihr inhalt
verbreitet werden die grundlage dafür
lieferte wohl die erfindung der
druckpresse um 1450 herum seitdem
konnten bücher in hohen auflagen
gedruckt werden
zudem gab es immer mehr leute die lesen
konnten während der aufklärung
lieferten verschwörungstheorien dann
den ersatz für den glauben viele leute
wandten sich in dieser zeit von der
religion ab und nicht mehr nur gott
wurde seitdem verantwortlich gemacht
dafür was in der welt so passiert
allerdings gibt es auch andere experten
und expertinnen die sich mit
verschwörungstheorien auseinander
gesetzen und der meinung sind dass es
wie so lange gibt wie die menschen es
erklären wir mit der evolution dass wir
menschen evolutionsbedingt vorsichtig
sein mussten um zu überleben forderte
demnach die bildung von
verschwörungstheorien für die menschen
weiß nämlich seit anbeginn sinnvoll
gewesen sich in gruppen zusammen zu tun
und sich anderen menschen gegenüber
misstrauisch zu zeigen weiter fakt
verschwörungstheorien sind gefährlich
für alle eine australische studie legt
nahe dass anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien dazu neigen
etablierte wissenschaftliche fakten
abzulehnen
beispielsweise halten wie das rauchen
für unschädlich um mit sie sich am
ende natürlich erst einmal weg
schreiben aber verschwörungstheorien
können nicht nur dazu führen dass
menschen sich selbst schaden vor allem
bei theorien die bestimmte gruppen von
menschen schlecht machen besteht das
risiko dass diese gruppen auch
körperlich angegriffen werden einige
forscher und forscherinnen sehen aber
auch vorteile in verschwörungstheorien
durch die skepsis können auch positives
bewirkt werden falls die theorien auf
echte probleme hinweisen wenn auch durch
argumente die nicht der wahrheit
entsprechen bus erfasst
verschwörungstheorien stiften
vermeintlich sind verschwörungstheorien
sind so erfolgreich weil sie den leuten
angebote liefern dinge zu erklären und
dabei sinn stiften allerdings so
vermeintlich psychologisch gesehen
bekommen ihre anhänger so also ein
exklusives wissen wodurch die gefahr
abwenden können und sich in sicherheit
wiegen ereignisse die in keinem
zusammenhang stehen finden den
verschwörungstheorien plötzlich
zueinander
doch gleichzeitig machen sie auch angst
doch was macht eine
verschwörungstheorie zu einer
waschechten verschwörungstheorie die
sind sich experten nicht ganz einig
einige definieren drei komponenten aus
denen die verschwörungstheorie steht
erstens ein plan der verfolgt wird
zweitens eine gruppe die ihn ausgeheckt
hat und ihn angeblich verfolgt und
brücken zu dem der charakter des
geheimen gut und böse juli ihren sich
diejenigen die verschwörungstheorien in
die welt setzen haben dieser definition
nach nichts gutes im sinn
ein weiteres wichtiges kriterium ist
anderen experten zufolge die vermeidung
der wahrheit die verschwörungstheorien
wie er spricht also eine offiziell
anerkannte version eines ereignisses
oder vorgang förder fakt
verschwörungstheorien sind heutzutage
sichtbarer als früher
durch das internet bekommt die
verwaltung von verschwörungstheorien
natürlich noch einmal eine ganz neue
dimension
das ist nicht verwunderlich die
verbreitung aber auch die vernetzung mit
anderen anhängern ist sehr viel
einfacher geworden allerdings gibt es
keine studien die belegen dass heute
tatsächlich mehr menschen als früher
an den glauben seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg werden verschwörungstheorien
in europa immer weniger ernst genommen
ganz im gegensatz zu der arabischen welt
und osteuropa beispielsweise dort gelten
wie für viele menschen als glaubhafter
und wind stiftender als medien wie
große fernsehsender oderzeitung
fünfter fakt anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien gibt es in allen
sozialen schichten zudem hinweise darauf
dass vor allem junge und er ungebildete
menschen an verschwörungstheorien
glauben doch anhänger wind wohl in
allen sozialen schichten zu finden
mehr aber noch bei menschen die sehr
religiös sind oft sind diejenigen fans
von verschwörungstheorien die ihre
eigene identität in gefahr sehen wie
zwei wenn männer über
vier jahren die laut studien häufig
verschwörungstheorien im netz
kommentieren viele von ihnen haben wohl
angst vor den konsequenzen der
emanzipation und globalisierung so der
erklärungsversuch der forscherinnen und
forscher festhalten kann man wohl dass
all diejenigen die sich in eine extreme
richtung bewegen weiß nur politisch
oder religiös anfällig sind für
verschwörungstheorien
denn viele von ihnen fühlen sich wohl
als außenseiter verschwörungen können
dann laut forschung herhalten um für
diesen zustand eine vermeintliche
erklärung zur fifa sechster fakt die
erste bekannte verschwörungstheorie ist
wo die über die illuminaten der jury
nach unserer heutigen definition ging wo
zu zeiten der französischen revolution
durch die welt gesteuert wo sind demnach
die revolution vom geheimbund der
illuminaten dieser bund existierte
allerdings schon damals nicht mehr
allerdings würde auch heute noch mit
einer weltverschwörung in zusammenhang
gebracht für die es aber keinerlei
beweise
sie packt die gegenargumente lassen an
herrn noch mehr daran glaubt wie geht
man am besten mit anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien jetzt fehlt es an
eindeutigen studien anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien sind aber wohl
noch am ehesten anfänglich für fakten
empfänglich sobald sie dann vollends
überzeugt sind kann es passieren dass
wir durch starke gegner haben die
argumente noch mehr an ihre theorie
glauben und damit also das gegenteil
erreicht wird bei impfgegner zum
beispiel gelten von ärzten vorgebrachte
argumente als beweis ihrer
verschwörungstheorie weil sie ja besagt
dass ärzte die pharmaindustrie
unterstützen und deshalb für das
impfen werden dann sind dann wirklich
hopfen und malz verloren wenn ihr nicht
verpassen wollen wenn ich mal wieder
eine abstruse verschwörungstheorie
auseinander nehmen dann wird mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit
evolutionstheorie endgültig bestätigt
er touristen auf verlorenem posten
da geht es um die kreationisten die ohne
jeden preis meinen dass gott gewesen
hier auf der erde erschaffen hat warum
das totaler blödsinn ist und die
evolutionstheorie im gegensatz bewiesen
dass erfahrt ihr wenn ihr auf das video
clip von ansonsten bis dann bleib dran